Hi, welcome back. In the last session
where we introduced value investing, we
talked about the different forms that
value investing can take. And one of the
forms we talked about was screening for
stocks, a passive version of value
investing. And this happens to be the
most widely practiced version of value
investing. What does that mean? You look
across companies and remember there are
thousands of publicly traded companies
and you screen for companies that you
think are cheap. Those screens can
either be qualitative screens. You're
looking for companies, good companies,
companies with good management. Good is
a fuzzy word and if you don't put a
number on it's a qualitative screen. So
are qualitative screens. I'll introduce
qualitative screens in this session.
Talk more about them in the next
session. But this session I'm going to
focus primarily on quantitative screens
where you look for stocks that are cheap
by looking at the numbers. Let's start
with qualitative screens. As I said,
just talk at least in the, you know, put
an overlay on them before we turn to the
quantitative screens. The essence of a
qualitative screen is you can't point to
a number. It's not in the financial
statements, but you think it matters
anyway. It can either be at the company
level or at the management level. At the
company level, these qualities can
include reputation for quality or
service, a loyal c employee force. After
all, they can carry you upwards. a loyal
customer base who keep coming back to
you to buy your products or that you
care about society and people. In fact,
in the last two decades, as you've seen
the focus on ESG and sustainability, one
of the arguments is companies that do
more for society, care more for society
should be worth more at the management
level. The quality qualities could
include as Warren Buffett did looking at
managers who are honest and accountable
being creative especially in a growth
company being capable. We'll talk more
about these qualitative screens later in
this class. But I want to focus as I
said in this session primarily on
quantitative screens and in three groups
of quantitative screens. The first are
book value screens where you compare
what a stock trades at relative to its
book value. In the most common version
of this, you compare the price per share
to the book value per share, either
trying to buy stocks that traded below
book value or at low multiples of book
value. You can have earnings screens
where you look at stocks that trade at
low multiples of earnings. Most widely
used version of this multiple of course
is the PE ratio, but you got enterprise
value versions of it. Enterprise value
to EBIT operating income or enterprise
value to EBIT DA, which is really more
of a cash flow than an earnings. And you
have cash yield screens where you look
for companies that deliver a cash flow
to you in the form usually of dividends,
high dividend yields. And in some cases,
investors add to these screens to make
sure they're not getting stocks that
look cheap but deserve to be cheap. So
let's start with pricetobook screens.
Pricetobook value. Here's what you're
doing. You're comparing the market price
per share to the book value of equity,
that accounting number for equity on
your balance sheet on a per share basis.
And here the evidence seems to be pretty
straightforward, pretty clear that low
priceto book stocks have historically
done better than high price to book
stocks. In fact, if you look at the
entire time period 1927 through 2024 and
you break stocks down into 10 classes
based on price to book from lowest to
highest, the lowest price to book stocks
earned 16.32%
on average and the highest price to book
stocks earned only 11.9%.
The lowest price to book stocks earned a
4.5% higher return than highest price to
book stocks. That settles the case,
right? But take a closer look at the
data because I've actually broken the
data down by time period and you'll
notice as you go through time that the
pricetobook advantage seems to be
fading. In fact, between 2011 and 2024,
low price to book stocks dramatically
underperformed high price to book
stocks. File that away because you're
going to notice a pattern as we look at
other screens as well. The argument that
stocks that have low price to book
ratios do better than high price to book
ratios is based on the entire time
period. But there's a fading towards the
end. However, if you look across markets
across pretty much every market, you do
see evidence that low price to book
stocks outperform high price to book
stocks in most markets. So in the US
historically, most markets low price to
book stocks have delivered higher
returns. Let's accept that as a premise
notwithstanding the 2011-24 evidence and
let's look at why even though it looks
like a surefire way of making money it
might not be. There are two things to
worry about when you go out and buy low
price to book stocks. The first is from
the farmer French studies from which
this low price to book stock was
originally bought. The argument that
farmer and French made was maybe this is
a proxy for risk. Maybe low price to
book stocks are riskier than they look
using traditional risk and return models
and what you're earning as a higher
return is compensation for risk. In
fact, the farmer French view of their
you know of the factors that they found
delivered excess returns was those
factors are more likely to be proxies
for risk than standins for ways to beat
the market. The second thing to worry
about is when you buy a low price to
book stocks, you might be buying a
lowquality company. What am I talking
about? Companies deliver value by taking
the money you they raise from equity and
putting into projects on which they
deliver a return in equity. If you're a
company that consistently delivers a
return equity that is less than your
cost of equity,
you can expect to earn or trade at a at
a price less than your book value. So
when you go out and buy low price to
book stocks, you might in effect be
getting stocks that are actually that
actually deserve to be cheap. So
something to think about as you embark
on that low price to book. There's one
other thing that I think we need to
factor in when we look at book values is
that as we move away from the 20th
century America which was built around
manufacturing companies, the 21st
century market built around technology
companies is an argument that book value
means less and less. There was a time
where people argue that book value was a
proxy for liquidation value. That if you
liquidated a company, you could get the
book value back. That's increasingly
untrue as you look at service and
technology companies. In fact, if you
add to it inconsistencies in accounting,
especially in the way in which
technology companies capital
expenditures, R&D, are being treated in
accounting statements, you could argue
that the book value technology companies
is massively understated. Which can then
explain why even though the pricebook
ratio today for you for the S&P 500 is
higher than it's ever been, it might not
be it might not be an indicator that
stocks are overvalued. So let's
summarize on price to book you're
comparing the price per share to the
book value of equity and historically
low price to book stocks have earned a
higher return than high price to book
stock. So that seems to have faded in
the last 14.
But that even that excess return if you
take the entire period could be a return
for taking on more risk or a return that
reflects the fact that these companies
take bad projects and increasingly book
value is getting less meaningful. So
that's price to book. Let's turn to
price earnings ratio. Again, if you look
at the the overall time period, there is
evidence that low price earning stocks
earn higher returns in high price
earning stocks. But then if you break it
down again and you get to the 2011 to
2024 period, you can see low PE stocks
start to underperform high PE stocks.
As with the earlier case, you're you're
seeing the fading
of the PE ratio effect. But over the
entire time period, low PE companies
have earn earned a higher return than
high PE companies. Much of value
investing's mystique is built around
this historical outperformance.
But here again, if you're an investor
buying low PE stocks, what do you need
to worry about? First, you have to worry
about the fact that the earnings might
be high risk. What does that mean? Well,
especially as you've got accounting
gaming, you can have high earnings
because you're doing really well or high
earnings because of accounting
manipulation.
So, that's one factor. The other is a
variant of the argument we made with low
price to book stocks. Maybe low PE
stocks are riskier for whatever reason.
The models don't capture that risk. So,
one is high-risisk earnings and with low
PE stocks, you might be getting a lot of
companies with high risk earnings. The
second is a tax issue. When we talked
about trading costs and taxes in session
six, we talked about the fact that when
you invest in high dividend yield
stocks, if you're a high tax rate
individual, you might end up with a
bigger tax burden than if you don't buy
if you buy stocks with low dividend
yields.
Low P stocks are more likely to be high
dividend paying stocks. And as a
consequence, there might be a tax burden
you face,
which means that after taxes, some of
those excess returns might disapp. And
thirdly,
you can have a stock that has low PE
ratio, but its earnings growth might be
zero, negative, or very low. In other
words, you might be just getting a a
bunch of companies that don't just have
low growth, but might be shrinking their
earnings. High-risk taxes and low growth
can sometimes get in the way of low PE
stocks actually delivering the returns
that look like excess returns.
In the last three or four decades,
you've seen a shift away from P ratios,
especially among equity research
analysts, to multiple, it's called the
EV to EIDA multiple. What is EV? EV is
enterprise value. Enterprise value is
market value of equity plus debt minus
cash. In other words, the market value
of the operating asset of the company
divided by EIDA, which is earnings
before interest, taxes, depreciation,
amortization. The people who use this
argue that it's a better measure than PE
because EIDA is a cash flow. It's not
quite true, but it is a cash flow, but
it's a very gross measure of cash flow.
The second argument is a purely
statistical argument with PE ratios.
When a company has negative earnings,
you lose it from your sample. So, you
could have a sector which has 30
companies and 15 of them might drop out
of your sample because they have
negative net income. There are companies
with negative EBIDA but there are far
fewer negative negative negative EIDA
companies than negative net income
companies.
The push back though is EIDA is a cash
flow but as I said it's a very gross
cash flow. It's before taxes before
capex. It's not a free cash flow. And as
with PE ratios, you have to worry about
the quality of growth and the level of
growth and checking for risk because who
knows what might be coming through as
cheap on an evida basis.
Here again though a caveat to changing
times as technology companies have
become a larger and larger component of
the market.
The way accountants estimate earnings at
technology companies and the what they
classify or don't classify as capex is
having an effect on the earnings that
these companies report. So PE and EVITA
are both affected by how accountants
read R&D at technology companies. Again
a note of caution as you go looking for
cheap companies based on any kind of
earnings multiple. So book value
multiples earnings multiples. Let's
complete the story by looking at
dividend years. If you remember the Ben
Graham screens, one of the screens of
course is the dividend yield as high
delivering a cash flow. In fact, I say
only half jokingly that Ben Graham's
dream of a great company was a bond with
price appreciation. Other words, the
dividend stood in for the coupon. In
this t this graph and the the numbers
below, you can see how low dividend
yield stocks compared to high dividend
yield stocks. And the highest dividend
yield stocks historically have earned a
higher return than the lowest dividend
yield or non-ividend paying companies.
Here again though the effect has
dissipated decreased especially in the
last 14 years. So as with the PE effect
and the price to book book effect the
dividend yield effect has also started
to lose its oomph in recent years. We'll
come back and address that more
generally. But across the entire time
period, there's the argument buying high
dividend paying stocks would have
delivered excess returns. In fact, there
are variants of this where um people
look at what's called the dogs of the
Dow where they look at the company the
largest dividend payers in the Dow 30
and you invest in those dividend
players. You have dividend aristocrats.
These are companies that not only pay
high dividends but have done it for
decades, sometimes a century. and you
invest in those companies. The people
investing based on dividends argue that
dividends are the only tangible return
of cash flows. That those free cash
flows we compute in valuation are only
on paper. So they're the only tangible
returns and that they're more
predictable than price appreciation
because companies have sticky dividends,
pay the same amount year after year. In
fact, to back up the notion that
dividends are sticky, take a look at
this graph. It looks at the percentage
of US companies each year that increase
dividends. That's a green column that
cut dividends. It's a red column. If I
pause right there, you can see about
four to five times more companies
increase dividends and cut dividends.
And even in really bad years like 2008,
far more companies increase dividends
and decrease them. But in every single
year, if you look at the blue column,
that's a companies that don't change
dividends, pay exactly what they did the
previous year. Most companies pay what
they did last year as dividends. And
that's where the stickiness comes in.
That's why investors who are
conservative like them because dividends
are predictable.
But even as you embark on this path of
looking for companies that pay high
dividends, especially high dividend
yields, here are some things you need to
watch out for. One is companies because
they have sticky dividends might
continue to pay dividends even as they
get into deeper and deeper trouble. In
fact, these dividends might be
unsustainable. You're saying, "But
they're paying them." Eventually,
they're going to run into a wall and
those dividends are going to disappear.
So, check to see whether the dividends
are sustainable. Say, "How would I do
that?" The ingredients you need to
estimate what a company can pay out are
right there in the financial statements.
If you go back and review the valuation
class, we talked about free cash flow
equity. The cash flow left over after
you've met every conceivable need.
That's potential dividend. If you have a
company in negative free cash flow
equity that's continuing to pay a
dividend that's potentially
unsustainable.
It could be that the company has low or
negative growth and that's why you it
looks cheap and you're earning a high
return for the moment. Or it could be a
company that where you know the
dividends get paid but you have a high
tax rate and you're going to pay a
higher taxes in the dividend. One final
point about any dividend based strategy
that you got to factor in. The world is
changing under you. In the US, as you
look at how companies return cash,
there's been a shift away from
dividends. And you can see that in this
graph where I graph out the dividends
every year going back to 1988 and the
stock buybacks every year. And this is
not just a short-term phase. It's a
long-term shift away from dividends to
buybacks. US companies are increasingly
shifting away from dividends to
buybacks. What does that mean? If you
buy a company just based on dividends,
it's entirely possible you might be
missing companies that are returning a
great amount of cash but doing it in the
form of buybacks. So it is a reality and
it's a reality you got to factor into
your investing.
One final theme when you screen for
cheap stocks
your objective when you're a value
investor is to find a cheap stock. But
one of your nightmares is you can end up
with what's called a value trap. You're
saying what's a value trap? A value trap
is a stock that looks cheap. Low PE, low
price to book, high dividend yield,
whatever your your your metric is, but
it stays cheap or becomes even cheaper
because the fundamentals in this company
have shifted in a negative way. In other
words, the market is reflecting the fact
that growth has become negative, margins
are decreasing, and you keep holding the
stock expecting it to revert back to
what it used to be. And increasingly in
a world where disruption is changing
entire sectors, there's a very real
chance that what looks cheap to you
might in fact be a value trap. So you
need to develop your defenses. And here
are some of the things that you might
that are worth thinking about. First is
if you're a value screener, then you
need to run accounting checks. When you
do PE ratios, rather than just divide by
last year's earnings, you might
normalize the earnings. You might adjust
the earnings for what you think are
accounting shortcomings. Or you can use
the Warren Buffett version of owner's
earnings.
Warren Buffett talks a lot about the
moat. And I think the there's a good
reason for the moat is a measure of
competitive
advantages. Even though it might just be
qualitative, it's better if you can make
it quantitative. Even if it's
qualitative, you might want to buy cheap
stocks. Stocks that look cheap but have
solid modes.
We'll talk more about margin of safety,
but a margin of safety basically means
you could be wrong and you want to give
yourself a buffer. So if you have a
margin of safety of 20% in the screening
word, you will buy stocks only they're
20 if the PE ratio is 20% below what it
should be or below the sector PE. You're
trying to give yourself a buffer. So do
what you can develop your protecting
armor. So if you are developing a
screening approach, start with the
recognition that the world has become
much easier for you to screen in than it
was 30 years ago. I have access luckily
to Capital IQ. Some have access to facts
that these are huge global databases and
screening can be done in minutes. You
can pick the screen screen for you can
run the Ben Graham screens in two
minutes.
But if you get carried away, you could
be screening for dozens and dozens of
things with no common theme attached to
them. So if you're you have a database
and you want to screen, here are the
things you should be screening for. You
want to screen for cheapness, low PE,
low price to book. Pick your metric.
Screen for cheapness. You're going to
get a bunch of stocks that trade at low
PE or low price to book or low EV debit.
Don't stop. Screen for low risk. Doesn't
have to be beta. Doesn't have to be
standard deviation. It could be variance
in earnings. You pick your poison for
risk. You want to screen for low risk.
You want cheap stocks that are low risk.
Then screen for growth. You don't want
to end up with companies that are
shrinking.
Put in a growth rate. Be reasonable. If
you want if your PE ratio screen is that
you want to buy stocks that trade less
than 15 times earnings, don't put a
growth rate of 50%. But you might put in
a growth rate of 10%. So you want low
cheapness, low risk, high growth. And
then look for quality growth. That's a
mo component. A return on equity that
exceeds a cost of equity. Return on
capital higher than the cost of capital.
Something that captures. You want cheap
companies with low risk and high growth
and high quality growth. And doing all
of that is much easier than it used to
be. And that's a mixed blessing. It's
great that it's easier. The fact that
everybody can do it might also mean that
the days of making excess returns just
based on screens are numbered.
So what do you need to succeed at
screening if you're a value screener?
First is you need a long time horizon.
And every single one of those graphs you
saw of low P stocks, low price to book.
Those returns are not every year. They
occur over long periods. You need a long
enough time horizon. Second, you need to
choose your screens well, which is you
can't just screen for PE and stop there.
As I said, you got to screen for growth
and risk. you are implicitly trusting
mean reversion. Things will revert back
to the way they used to be and you have
to worry whether that's still the case
in a business with disruption. Spread
your bets. If you're going to pick
stocks with low PE and high growth,
don't just pick the one stock with the
lowest P and the highest growth. Do it
across 10 or 15 or 20.
Law of large numbers work in your favor.
And watch out for taxes and transactions
costs because they can eat away what
looks like returns on paper can be eaten
away by those.
I hope you found the session useful and
I thank you very much for listening.